and if we ever do another podcast
because we're running out of time for
your session we can talk about something
that was
really tough in my life that i had to do
if we ever do another podcast well can
you give me a hint about it
it's when i did the hard stern show oh
wait wait wait
you did the howard stern show well it
was one
i ended up doing it twice and i
shouldn't have gone back but what was it
what
he was just asking you because it's
howard he asked personal questions
um so the first time was kind of gross
but i got away with it
and then i did a butterfly effect too
and i got a lot of pressure from the
studio and from a lot of people to go on
hardship my first
reaction was and this is what i should
have stuck to no
it's not my it's not my deal like my
life isn't that like that i don't have a
tawdry existence it's fairly basic
um but then they kept asking and asking
in the studio's like you got to do this
and so i said okay i'll go and do this i
can do this
because last experience i had with
howard he's a nice enough guy like he's
smart
he knows his stuff you just have to know
what you're doing when you go in the
ring with him
and i did not and so they they do these
pre-interviews with you where they ask
you something so they gave me this line
of making up these like west van parties
that that our family does which is like
we're known for
like west van is known for swinging and
all that jazz and all that west
vancouver
west vancouver yeah i don't know the
group and i
i don't understand why it happens but i
don't judge okay
anyways pre-interview they said make
this [ __ ] up and then we'll segue we'll
have a little laugh and then we'll segue
into talking about your show
and so i did that and then they didn't
let it go and there was no way i could
get around it it got worse and worse and
worse as i was sitting there
and then then they started making fun of
my outfit
and saying i looked amish they're just
trying to get any kind of
reaction out of me this is on the actual
show yeah this is on the show like if
you youtube and now a bunch of people
might use it so howard's interviewing
you
howard's interviewing me and and they're
making fun of you
oh yeah because they realize that it
wasn't me like i was trying to play this
game if i had been like them
and gone in there and known how to like
work the room and stuff they probably
would have chilled
but the worst experience of that and i
cannot believe i didn't birth
i don't know why i didn't leave but he
had two cronies
that threatened they were standing there
off camera
and they were going to drop trow and
show me their business to try to get
another reaction out of me
like it was just a nightmare and all i
could think is
i've like brought so much shame to my
family and that's all i could think
about
was like why did you do this if it had
just been me i would have been like
that was really embarrassing and dumb
but i felt so
embarrassed for my family because it was
so tawdry and um well wait a minute but
you were on his show before
we talked about it to kristen and that's
it well you were um on the show
on tower stream once before you said
yeah
and that was fine well it was okay it
was still like kind of embarrassing and
it was time
but it was okay enough for you to come
back so you felt like it wasn't going to
get
i felt like it was going to be like kind
of like the soft footing it right and
something light and joke and then talk
about the movie i was supposed to get on
there and talk about the movie and they
wouldn't do it right they couldn't let
go of this
ridiculous story that they told me to
make up
and um and i just couldn't figure out a
way to get out
and it was over and howard was really
nice like he came up afterwards he's
like are you okay you seem like
like i think they thought it was part of
their show right
and and i'm like yeah yeah yeah and i
got out of there
and i went downstairs and i started like
i was bawling in the room
in the building below and somebody
reported that back
and then it was like headlines erica
left howard stern crying and
like it's taken me this has been well
over a decade 15 16 years to even talk
about it
because it was so embarrassing you know
what but it's good to talk about it now
and especially in this world where we're
talking about
our past and it's like you know what i
still learn something valuable
from that like go with your gut and if
you can't do something or you don't
think you should or it's not your deal
like don't be so afraid of authority
just say no
and i have a hard time saying no if my
boss says i'm supposed to do something
right
yeah especially if they're not like uh
maybe you weren't prepared enough
obviously or
you know and i know i don't think you
know when i've listened to howard stern
i don't think you know and i was always
a huge fan i was always dying to get on
the show i guess i was never big enough
obviously to be on the show but i always
used to love howard and he used to talk
about smallville
and you know yeah he was and he was
great and
so i don't i don't picture him like i
think that like he had no idea that you
were
probably that's what you said you were
like i don't think he didn't know that i
was really upset and so
because you could fake it pretty good
you're you're strong enough you're like
yeah
and then you're you're dying inside like
oh it was brutal and how long was it how
long was the interview
it felt like it was like four hours long
it was probably 20 minutes
but it was just like oh my god
and so now i look at those things in my
life and i try to say okay what would
what would i say in response to that it
was interesting i was talking to kristen
about it and i still felt like it was
all my fault and kristen's like
you know in scenarios like that it isn't
all your fault like
they shouldn't have been threatening to
show you their penises
like that's not okay